make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
turn and face the strange such a change
it is one of my favorite youtubers who
hasn't uploaded in like two years I got
names seananners opened up a video like
that once and I just died laughing I
thought it was hilarious what's going on
guys this is wrong you guys holding on I
know it's rough out there folks
try to hold on as best you can to help
you get through all of this we are back
with another installment and our what-if
series where we make up our own stories
and today we're focusing on two villains
that have been at the forefront of
comics over the last year or so and
asking the question what would happen if
these two merged of course I'm referring
to the Batman who laughs and carnage so
what would happen if the Batman who
laughs became the carnage simian or at
least bonded with the carnage simian
well I think to answer that question we
need to briefly go over who the Batman
who laughs is for those who might not be
familiar so the Batman who laughs was a
central figure in the Dark Knight's
medal event that ran through 2017 and
2018 and he's been one of DC's most
prominent villains ever since and
originally the Batman who last was the
Bruce Wayne of earth- 22 which is part
of the dark multiverse which as its name
suggests is a parallel multiverse where
everything is evil now on this earth The
Joker learns that Bruce Wayne is
actually Batman and he kills
Commissioner Gordon and hatches a plan
to release the Joker toxin throughout
Gotham City hoping that it will cause a
lot of children to see their parents die
and in doing so they will be exposed to
the same trauma that caused Bruce Wayne
to become Batman and that experience
combined with exposure to the Joker
toxin will create a series of Batman
Joker hybrids of course Batman comes to
stop the Joker and at that time actually
kills him but upon the death of the
Joker a concentrated form of the toxin
is released and Bruce is doused with the
chemical and so over time this results
in Bruce Wayne's transformation into the
very sort of hybrid that the Joker had
intended which has Batman's intelligence
and physical skills as well as Joker's
psychosis and sadism and so one of the
things that Batman who lost is able to
do is travel throughout the Dark
multiverse and recruit other evil
versions of Batman to his cause and we
saw him do this in dark nights metal we
also see that his knowledge is somewhat
based on the Multiversity book by Grant
Morrison of which the Batman who laughs
actually has a copy of and so
he can get his hands on an actual kind
book published by VC in our world I
think it only stands to reason did he
travel to our world to acquire it and if
he did that he would also have the
ability to get copies of books published
by Marvel as well so for our story this
is how the Batman who last is going to
learn about the existence of carnage
this symbian and so once he learns about
the simian he's going to set out to
acquire it by travelling to the Marvel
Universe now most of you are probably
familiar with the karna simian but it is
an offspring of the venom simian itself
and while venom was bonded with Eddie
Brock and Eddie was in jail the semi had
helped Eddie escape but left his
offspring behind and so the offspring
which we know is carnage then bonded to
Eddie cellmate a psychotic guy named
Cletus Kasady and this is the point
where the Batman who laughs is going to
pop up in the main Marvel Universe just
before the carnage symbiote bonds with
Cletus and what we're going to see is
that Batman who laughs will actually
kill Cletus Kasady so that he is the
only living thing in the cell for
carnage to bond to and so once that
happens we have a carnage eyes Batman
who laughs he goes back to the DC
Universe since he doesn't really care
about the moral universe and has really
focus on terrorizing the main DC
Universe especially that universes
version of Bruce Wayne and so now the
question becomes really what's different
about the Batman who laughs once he's
bonded to the carnage symbiote while
keeping in mind that he already
possesses Bruce Wayne's intellect
detective skills in combat prowess as
well as the psychosis of the Joker
through a mental standpoint the real
changes from Cletus Kasady to that man
who laughs Arthur the Batman who laughs
is a lot smarter and tells a lot more
jokes but the psychotic nature would
largely remain the same and of course
the carnage symbiote is going to grant
the Batman who laughs extra abilities
including basically all of spider-man's
powers since the Venom symbiote has
those abilities from being bonded to
Peter Parker and the Connor symbiote
inherited those abilities from venom and
so he'll also have the ability to use
the carnage symbiote to heal from injury
shape-shift including creating weapons
from the symbiote and changing his size
so with these newfound powers the Batman
who laughs is going to be able to cause
even more havoc than normal and so
what's gonna happen is that this new
character who we're going to call the
carnage who last is going
dude that's an awesome name the carnage
who laugh do the carnage who laughs
how amazing is that name but in any
event with this new character that we're
calling the karna - laughs he's going to
begin terrorizing Gotham in a major way
and there's essentially going to be a
lot of death to Gotham citizens which of
course is going to draw the attention of
Batman now as Batman engages his enemy
however he's soon going to realize that
he's dealing with something completely
different than anything he's ever seen
during his previous encounters with the
Batman who lost when the two of them
engage in battle Batman becomes quickly
overwhelmed and just manages to escape
with his life thanks to his armor but
he's badly wounded now he puts out a
call for help and is answered by many of
the bat family and they prepare to go
into battle once more after being
equipped with some upgraded armor v
Batman designs for all of them now even
with their combined forces however the
karna - laughs proves to be a difficult
opponent to defeat and when they begin
to gain the upper hand
the carnage ooh laughs does something
totally unexpected
he imbues each of his Robins with a
separate symbian now these Robins were
Ravens whatever you want to call them
each go in a different direction leaving
a trail of death and destruction in
their wake
now this force of the team to split up
and therefore weakens all of their
efforts leading to the decision that
they need to retreat and regroup to the
Batcave but before they can fully
execute their planned retreat Damian
Wayne is killed by one of the symbiote
enhance rabid Robins after getting
isolated from the rest of the group and
so this basically raises the stakes for
Batman in a way that really nothing else
could have because now the carnage who
lost has directly taken his biological
son away from them now the other thing
that happens is that Cassandra Cain
formerly Batgirl and now known as orphan
is infected by a symbian but the team
does not discover this until they get
back to the Batcave and when they find
out Cassandra willingly goes into
isolation and a special containment cell
so that she does not unwittingly harm
her teammates and so ultimately she self
isolates because we here at commis
explained are nothing if not topical I
feel like that was a terrible joke to
make but come on guys she's practicing
social distancing six feet six feet is
the rule so the whole bat family is
essentially reeling right they've lost
Damian and one of their own is now
infected now in typical Batman fashion
Bruce dives headfirst into figuring out
anything and everything he can about the
symbian as a way of avoiding
dealing with the grief of losing his son
in a well-adjusted normal healthy way
but all he can really figure out about
the symbian is that a symbiotic in
nature and that there seemingly has
never been anything like it before in
the DC universe now Batman
does not have a major breakthrough until
he receives an unexpected visitor from
another universe
this suddenly appears in the Batcave now
after an initial standoff the man tells
Bruce that he's there to help because he
has knowledge of the symbiote and how to
defeat it and so he introduces himself
as Reed Richards but all of us who are
reading this recognize that while it is
Reed Richards we know him better not as
mr. fantastic but as the maker the
ultimate universe version of Reed
Richards and so of course Batman doesn't
know that this is an evil version of
Reed says he's never heard of any
version of Reed Richards before but the
two of them begin to work together
alongside each other and develop a plan
of attack centered around exploiting the
symbiotes weaknesses sound and heat now
with that information in Batman's vast
resources they build a suit of armor
that emits high-frequency Sonic's as
well as powerful flamethrowers and so
after testing his armor on the symbiote
bonded with Cassandra he goes into
battle with the carnage who lasts
and with this foolproof game plan in
place he's able to separate the simian
from their host and capture the symbiote
in a containment unit developed by the
maker there was all the symbiotes
contained that Batman who last reverts
to his normal self and he and his
Robbins retreat and so with the threat
of the Batman who last neutralized
Batman and the maker go back to the
Batcave and the maker take sisimiut back
to his universe now Batman views this as
a partial victory the Batman who last is
still at large and he's lost his son
Damian for the second time the maker
however views this as a total victory
now if you've been keeping up with the
absolute carnage story that came out and
ended pretty heavily recently a little
while ago you know that the maker has
been trying to assemble a codex of all
the symbionts and now he has five
symbiotes at his disposal to unleash on
the marvel universe which they've never
seen before
since the carnage symbiote was
immediately taken to the DC Universe
after having been spawned and so the
Batman status quo is shaken up and now
there's a new threat to the Marvel
Universe as well and so I think the
story is pretty effective at creating
some big rippling effects that will be
felt in both universes the biggest
takeaway from all this is the
post-credit moment yes we're gonna start
adding post-credit scenes to our stories
because there's anything that we as
coming book fans like is post-credits
scenes right so pick up with this this
post credit scene might pick up with
this post credit scene and he basically
got a carnage symbiote that managed to
separate right the man who last sent a
carnage symbian out there into the world
that nobody was supposed to know about
now this carnage symbiote would bond
itself to the Green Lantern Hal Jordan
not because of the Green Lantern Hal
Jordans gonna be a new host that's not
what's gonna happen it's because the
symbiote has somewhere to go in its
dealings and it's not as that it gained
from the Batman who laughs it learned
about the greater universe in DC Comics
and learned that in DC Comics in this DC
universe there is a planet filled with
beings who are full of rage and so the
carnage symbiote takes Hal Jordan they
fly out to the middle of nowhere to a
planet called is mult and the carnage
symbiote abandons Hal Jordan and then
stays on the planet itself until it
comes across the return of the Red
Lanterns led by none other than
Atrocitus with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
let me know if you want to see a video
on
Atrocitus as carnage right a carnot a
carnage carnage eyes red lantern let me
know if you guys want to see that
because I honestly think that would be
beast we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you guys are new here to come
this explain and make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]